[Musica]
anche voi stamattina vi siete svegliati
e avete lasciato a malincuore le vostre
lenzuola di cotone avete mangiato una
brioche 5 cereali o un biscotto alla
crusca avete sorseggiato il caffè magari
un caffè con lo zucchero poi vi siete
lavati i denti con un dentifricio al
mentolo avete levato il corpo con un
sapone profumato alla vaniglia idratato
il viso con una crema all'aloe vera
magari avete preso un aspirina perché
leggermente influenzate avete buttato
giù la nota della spesa su un tavolo di
legno in cucina e poi vi siete
affacciati al balcone o alla finestra
guardando oltre poche piante di geranio
interrogandoli che tempo farà oggi e non
siamo ancora usciti di casa
ebbene è bene cosa c'è di fondamentale e
silenzioso dietro quanto gli ho
descritto
che cosa si nasconde dietro questi gesti
che compiamo quotidianamente sono le
piante il cotone nelle nostre lenzuola
il caffè nascosto nella capsula usa e
getta lamenta nel dentifricio
l'orchidea vaniglia nel sapone le piante
giocano un ruolo fondamentale per la
vita dell'uomo sulla terra al punto che
potremmo semplicemente dire che senza le
piante sul nostro pianeta non ci sarebbe
vita
le piante erano sulla terra prima
dell'uomo e si deve alle piante
la nostra presenza prima di tutto le
piante sono i polmoni verdi della terra
assorbono l'anidride cad all'atmosfera e
producono l'ossigeno che respiriamo con
la traspirazione svolgono un ruolo
importantissimo nel ciclo dell'acqua
addirittura le leguminose grazie alla
simbiosi con alcuni batteri sono in
grado di fissare l'azoto atmosferico e
renderlo disponibile per gli esseri
viventi
le piante sono alla base della catena
alimentare forniscono alimenti per gli
albi erbivori ed esiste una miriade di
piante di interesse alimentare per lui
senza trascurare il ruolo che le piante
hanno nell'evoluzione del clima del
suolo del paesaggio si deve al mondo
vegetale la profonda modifica
dell'ambiente terrestre che ha
consentito lo sviluppo di forme di vita
via via più complesse fino ad arrivare
all'uomo e oggi si deve alle piante la
protezione del nostro ambiente
pensate alle piante sui versanti
montuosi o sulle rive dei fiumi a queste
funzioni se ne aggiungono tante altre
la sintesi di principi attivi ancora
oggi utilizzatissimi medicina
l'acido salicilico ad esempio è un
potentissimo antinfiammatorio che si
estrae dal salice ed è alla base della
comune aspirina il mentolo che si estrae
dalla menta
pensate agli usi delle piante nella
biomassa per la produzione di biomassa
di energia agli usi delle piante
nell'industria tessile in edilizia in
falegnameria
le piante sono importantissime per la
nostra vita
eppure noi difficilmente ce ne
accorgiamo che siano in un grande parco
poi in un piccolo giardinetto urbano in
un paesaggio agricolo oppure in un bosco
naturale
noi non le notiamo veramente per noi
restano un generico verde tranquilli
questo non è un problema solo nostro
il fenomeno è talmente diffuso che nel
1998 due biologi vegetali americani
elizabeth chandler james wonder si hanno
coniato l'espressione plant blindness
cecità alle piante proprio per
descrivere l'incapacità di vedere le
piante dell'ambiente circostante
alzi la mano chi in questa foto ha
guardato e ha visto prima la leonessa è
molto dopo l'albero
siamo la maggioranza inizialmente si
pensava che questo meccanismo fosse
dovuto alla visione antropocentrica del
nostro pianeta e ai conseguenti
pregiudizi per i quali ad esempio le
piante sono veramente sommariamente
trattate nel nostro normale percorso
scolastico
in realtà alla base di questo fenomeno
c'è un vero e proprio problema cognitivo
un byas cognitivo che limita la nostra
visione delle piante
il nostro cervello infatti non è in
grado di elaborare tutti i dati che
riceve dai nostri sensi e imparato a
selezionare le informazioni che
provengono dall'ambiente
aggiungiamoci anche che le piante sono
organismi mobili non interagiscono
spesso sono innocue e che nell'ambiente
in cui l'uomo si è voluto erano
dappertutto e sovraccarica vano i nostri
sensi
ecco perché gli uomini primitivi hanno
imparato a ignorare le piante
concentrando la loro attenzione sui
potenziali pericoli come individuare un
carnivoro la leonessa della foto
precedente che poteva fare la differenza
tra la vita e la morte wonders infatti
definisce la cecità alle piante la plant
blindness un necessario difetto umano ma
questo meccanismo che all'inizio della
nostra evoluzione era un vantaggio
competitivo
oggi ci impedisce di comprendere
realmente qual è il motore della vita
sulla terra e non solo sulla terra la
terra è nota come pianeta verde the
green planet perché proprio è ricoperta
di verde ricoperta di piante a
differenza degli altri piani pianeti del
sistema solare come ad esempio marte il
pianeta rosso sul quale ad oggi non
ancora stata identificata forma di vita
per darvi un elemento in più
a questo proposito da oltre 20 anni con
il mio team di ricerca del dipartimento
di agraria dell'università di napoli
federico ii
ci stiamo interessando delle
problematiche della coltivazione delle
piante in sistemi bio rigenerativi di
supporto alla vita nello spazio
di che si tratta dunque se le piante
sono così importanti per la vita
dell'uomo sulla terra perché dovrebbero
essere meno importanti per la nostra
sopravvivenza in qualunque ambiente
extraterrestre la possibilità di
missioni spaziali di lunga durata della
lunga permanenza dell'uomo su
piattaforme orbitanti
con colonie su luna o su marte è legata
alla nostra capacità di creare degli eco
sistemi artificiali dei sistemi bio
rigenerativi di supporto e alla vita in
cui le piante svolgeranno un ruolo
biologico fondamentale rigenerare l'area
con la fotosintesi purificare l'acqua
con la traspirazione produrre cibo
magari riutilizzando parzialmente gli
scarti umani gli scarsi dell'equipaggio
gli scarti organici quindi vedete che
anche la nostra strada verso marte è
costellata dalle piante le piante sono
importanti per la vita dell'uomo ovunque
e noi spesso lo ignoriamo se ne parla
pochissimo
ovviamente la cecità dei piante la plant
blindness è acutizzata dal fatto che
oggi la gran parte della popolazione
umana vive in città e abbiamo tutti
quanti sporadici contratti con la natura
in generale e in particolare con le
piante i nostri figli quasi non
riconoscono più i vegetali che portiamo
a tavola noi stessi li compriamo spesso
lavati confezionati trasformati già
cucinati ignorando tutto ciò che c'è
dietro il processo che circonda la loro
produzione
l'agricoltura che è stata centrale nello
sviluppo della nostra società e nella
creazione della biodiversità e del
paesaggio agrario che oggi l'italia può
vantare
tutto ciò porta a un disinteresse a
sottostimare le piante e la loro
importanza per la nostra vita la salute
l'ambiente l'economia e sfocia in uno
scarso interesse per la loro conoscenza
la loro tutela conservazione e per la
valorizzazione del nostro incredibile
patrimonio vegetale la blunt blindness
cecità alle piante e il conseguente
crescente disinteresse dell'opinione
pubblica per il mondo vegetale nel suo
complesso
i limitati i fondi per la ricerca nella
produzione vegetale
oggi rappresentano un grosso rischio a
fronte della necessità di sfamare una
popolazione mondiale crescente in un
contesto globale caratterizzato inoltre
da scarsità di risorse naturali come
suolo acqua dai cambiamenti climatici
dal dall estinzione di specie vegetali
animali che procede a un tasso che non
ha precedenti e che renderanno difficile
il futuro delle produzioni vegetali le
decisioni che saremo chiamati a prendere
per una crescita sostenibile richiedono
una presa di coscienza da parte della
società sull'importanza delle piante e
sul ruolo cruciale crea che avranno
nella ricerca di soluzioni possibili
cosa possiamo fare un'azione individuale
moltiplicata per milioni crea un
cambiamento globale
se ciascuno di noi acquisisce
consapevolezza sull'importanza delle
piante per la nostra sopravvivenza
se ne cominceremo gli amici se lui
insegneremo ai nostri figli
potremmo dire di stare lavorando insieme
per un futuro migliore un futuro più
verde perché il verde non è un solo un
colore lo vedete adesso l'albero grazie
[Applauso]